I Love New York I love ah so you know
this opportunity is a kind of a match
made in heaven for me and so today I
want to tell everyone why I think that
mental health is a field of opportunity
for data science and for our and for
people who are you know practition of
these tools and so my story how I got
here seven years ago I had zero ability
to code I had no training in computer
science or anything five years ago I
went to Seattle for a summer I took this
selfie with Hadley and all of my friends
in grad school were extremely jealous
about three years ago founded a mental
health company called spring health
again no business degree you know
probably grossly inappropriate or a
responsible decision of me to find a
company and then a year and a half ago
our company started giving out free
mental health care to people who work at
companies that we partner with huge
shout out to work bench Jess and John
who invested in our around and so spring
health our mission is to help
individuals and organizations thrive by
eliminating every barrier to mental
health
we do that by partnering with companies
like those that are listed on right all
the way from you know small startups
like those in New York like Zola or
MongoDB all the way up to you know
pretty big companies 150,000 employee
groups like gap or Whole Foods and they
pay us to go and give out free mental
health care to everyone that works for
them and they do it
because the the general space of mental
health care right now is a little bit
broken it starts out here this is very
long and winding and confusing journey
but I think you'll see why it's
important to go through it it starts out
here at the top left people feel bad
that you know they're not sure why they
might feel sad or anxious or they're not
sleeping properly and they're not sure
why that's because there's a lot of
confusion about these conditions there's
a lot of stigma people don't really
openly talk about it although that is
changing now hopefully you know they
pluck up the courage and they go and
seek treatment
the nice thing at least about mental
health conditions is that most of them
are highly treatable they're all pretty
common but pretty treatable and you know
by some extraordinary fortune some of
them actually go and get care in the
u.s. is very very complicated people
might not know they might not
the domain knowledge they might not know
the difference between a psychiatrist
and the psychologist and the therapist
or a social worker they're probably
pretty confused about the way that
insurance works there's you know co-pays
and deductibles and coinsurance and then
things that in-network or out-of-network
and may be accepted or may not be
accepted this whole process is very
confusing particularly for people who
are struggling at the time but fingers
crossed they go they see a provider they
get a diagnosis and actually nationally
at that point about 30% of those people
never show up again and those are people
who are kind of falling through the
cracks as many reasons that we're going
to touch upon but let's say that they do
you know start treatment provider gives
them something like an antidepressant or
like a course of therapy and what
actually happens here really is that
people go through this process of trial
and error while they figure out what
works well for them
so providers have tons of different
things that they can do for you there's
all these different medications there
are all these different kinds of
therapies and they do work over all but
what works for one person might not work
for another and so there's this long you
know period of trial and error where
people bounce between treatments until
they eventually recover which is a great
outcome you know there are a few people
left at the bottom of this funnel but
unfortunately by the end within one year
from that person recovering about 40% of
those people will unfortunately have
relapsed and be back in a slightly worse
position than they started it sounds bad
right but it's important to bear in mind
things are actually getting better in
this space it was only 80 or 100 years
ago where treatment mostly consisted of
things like asylums and physical
restraint was one way that we dealt with
mental health conditions about 30 to 50
years ago we kind of had the advent of
antidepressants these medications that
reliably will help people feel better
different kinds of therapy to help
people understand how their thoughts and
feelings and behaviors are all related
and how we can change that to make it a
little bit better and but that you know
the overall situation today is that we
have a bunch of things that kind of work
but there's this trial and error process
to figure out what's going to work for
each individual and I think that that's
going to change at least that's our hope
which is that in some near future we
might be in a world where we can be more
proactive we can figure out who's going
to have a problem we can figure out how
we can get them connected to care sooner
how we can try and match them with types
of treatment that might be more more
likely to work for that person as an
individual and hopefully we
have a more effective system in total
and I think that it's important to
stress that I think that our is gonna
play a huge part ah you know if that's
your favorite flavor but certainly data
science more generally is going to play
a huge part in that and so today I'm
just going to highlight in the next 10
minutes or so 5 examples where our
and/or data science are improving mental
health right now and so parts of that
journey that I outlined that are
currently being improved by tools that
were developed completely and are and
kind of with data science philosophies
behind them and they'll be across that
whole journey that I that I mentioned in
the beginning of that journey right had
some people who were good
and some people who will eventually be
bad and I think at a high level it's
very important and helpful for us to
know which individuals might eventually
go on to have to experience some
unfortunate outcome and so suicide is
pretty much the most salient that we can
pick in mental health it's actually the
tenth leading cause of death right now
in the United States and so suicide you
know attempt to you know often fatal but
certainly rare and so that actually puts
providers in a tricky position because
they don't know who that they should be
worrying about they know that they
should be worrying because a grand scale
these things are a big problem but they
don't know who they need to worry about
and so this was some work that was done
out in Seattle by the the University of
Washington team and Kaiser a research
group out of Kaiser and what they did
was they went and linked state death
records so information that the
government maintains about who died and
how they died
and linked those death records back to
their electronic medical record that
they have from all of their own health
systems to develop a risk prediction
model that would tell us how likely each
individual person is to eventually go on
and have a suicide related behavior or a
suicide attempt or you know maybe a
suicide death but be able to kind of
relate their electronic medical record
data before that happens to that you
know future adverse event and they you
know you the paper is here in case I
don't want to look into it but they used
you know are the hallway they use the
gloom net packet package to fit an
elastic net model which is a you know
very powerful and powerful and fast
fitting algorithm they used for each to
you know distribute this large workload
many computers or many calls within a
computer and putting it into production
actually is really easy because they can
just take the glim net coefficients
it's just actual math apparently people
know how to do this and then you could
just apply the coefficients to the back
to that passive EMR data so no one has
to do anything but these algorithms that
run in the background are able to tell
physicians who they should be worrying
about and so the top 5% of these risk
scores that come out of this algorithm
just based on passive data actually
capture 40% more than 40% of all future
adverse events from this population so
allows the clinicians to really focus in
on just a few people rather than
expending resources everywhere but that
sample that they're focusing on is
enriched for these bad events and so we
can try and focus on the people who are
who are at higher risk of having an
unfortunate thing thing that we want to
avoid I mentioned that when people get
that diagnosis you know just broadly in
the United States about half of those
people never come back there's tons of
reasons why this happens and you know
they might you know say that they can't
afford the cost they might not know how
it works with their insurance they might
be too busy they might be scared that
we're going to force them to take
medications or commit them to a
psychiatric hospital and the tons and
tons of reasons why but very difficult
again to know what that individual
person will see as their own reason why
they're not going to get care and so
this is actually work that we did Spring
Health in collaboration with a couple of
different universities around the world
Yale Oxford and a date science group out
in London where we used that patient's
symptoms and socio-demographic profile
when they got that diagnosis with the
physician and use that to actually rank
the reasons why people those people
would be most likely not to get care so
out of all of the possible reasons come
up with some kind of recommendation
engine that will tell us or rank the
most likely reasons why an individual
might not get care again you know our
through and through actually boost was
the algorithm as a package for fitting
gradient boosted machines the whole
thing was done in carat which is
extremely important to keep yourself
sane when you're when you're fitting and
validating these these models and
streamlining the whole process and then
we actually developed an open sourced a
library that we built ourselves called
HT boost explainer that is actually
clinic
facing that helps clinicians understand
how a model arrived at a prediction for
any one individual so you know if I come
in and I'm a you know a 35 year old
white male who has symptoms X Y & Z how
did the algorithm think about putting
all of those pieces together when it
decided that I was too busy for care or
I was worried about what my boss is
going to say if they found out that I
got treatment and again allows us to do
things like anticipate barriers
anticipate the reasons why people might
not be willing to go into care and so
that we can try and do something about
it and tailor that individuals
experience and the healthcare system so
that we can offer them treatment
approaches that might be more acceptable
or more amenable for them third example
that I wanted to touch upon was really
getting to the heart of this issue of
trial and error that goes on in mental
health clinicians have all of these
different options there may be 50 FDA
indicated treatments for depression
there you know a bazillion medications
there are all of these different kinds
of psychotherapy different ways that
those psycho therapies work but again
clinician doesn't know upfront what's
going to work for you maybe if I go into
therapy
maybe I'll have a terrible experience
and I'll hate my therapist and I won't
get better and maybe if I actually then
go and take lexapro or something like
that and then maybe I'll have a very
good response and so this was work that
we did while I was still back at Yale we
actually took data from a bunch of
pharmaceutical partners from randomized
control trials that were done either in
industry or by CR OS clinical research
organizations or by the National
Institute of Health or FDA registration
trials and bring all of those into a
common space so that we can train again
a machine learning algorithm that can
predict given what you look like before
treatment predict what your what likely
events are going to happen to you are
you likely to recover conditional on
your taking certain kinds of treatment
again to train all of this actually
abuse and carrot gets you a very very
long way there may be ways that you can
do things slightly better I think if we
did it see today I think that this would
probably still give us most of that
performance that we got and in terms of
putting it into production there's a
package called our in Ruby which is a
really helpful binder that helps
that allows you to run or to connect an
AR you know an AR evaluator that can
receive these receive information about
a patient and then return back model
predictions and have that communicate
with a back-end server that might be
written in Ruby for example again it's
it's important to bear in mind that the
technology that we build can make a huge
impact on individual patient outcomes in
this case we showed in that first paper
in The Lancet there's in the top right
that when people took the treatment that
was recommended for them they were
actually two times more likely to get
better in that first episode of
treatment than if a psychiatrist even
won a large academic Medical Center had
made a recommendation based on clinical
intuition the third example that I want
to give is not stats heavy I think this
is a great example to show like how far
you can get we've just kind of pure
intuition building building tools that
really can just help clinicians and kind
of help the problem without having to
rely too heavily on stats or there's no
fancy modeling or no fancy stats really
going on here this is an example from
the United Kingdom's National Health
Service they have a single-payer system
in there everyone can go get free
treatment from the National Health
Service and they actually use data to
set expectations for the patient and for
the provider about what treatment
success looks like about what your
symptoms are likely to look like as you
go into treatment and as you continue
treatment in this case what they do is
they go and get all of the people that
they've treated before in these large
registries they have millions of
patients that they've treated over the
last you know five or ten years or so
and then they they use packages like LME
for and NL me4 to fit growth curve
models but really the idea here is that
they take all of the people they've ever
seen before and then they just plot that
back to the clinician but giving them
some guardrails so we say of all of the
people that we've treated before this is
what the worst ten percent of outcomes
look like and this is what the best ten
percent of outcomes look like and then
all they do is show you what this
patient looks like on their own you know
unique journey and then they'll give you
an alert if you ever go outside of those
two so you know in this case you can see
this patient starts off and it's going
okay but then you know something happens
and
they fall into this this red zone that
has shown back to the clinicians and
then the clinician is told hey you know
this looks like whatever's going on here
this looks abnormally bad for us you
know this is already in the the worst
ten percent of outcomes given everything
that we know from all of the people that
we treat and then they give that they
give that information to the care team
and so that the care team can have a
conversation amongst themself and say
hey do we know what's going on here is
there some kind of external reason why
this might have happened or do we need
to have a conversation with that patient
and let them know hey you know what
we're doing right now isn't working we'd
love to have a conversation about
different treatment strategies that we
could take you know we really want to
help get you back on track this is a
super simple innovation from a data
science perspective right there's really
not that much going on on the modeling
side but the impact can be pretty
profound so a randomized control trial
of this approach this framework the
results of which is shown on the right
so if you randomized people to see the
same sets of providers in two different
cases but in one case they given this
kind of visualization and they're given
these heads up on patients that are not
recovering and on the other side they're
treated by the same people but without
this technology supporting the
clinicians you actually see that failure
rates for treatment are actually two
times lower if they were given this
heads-up about you know someone's
progress not being on track so a great
example of data science done at scale
used every single day in the National
Health Service that really didn't depend
on on that sophisticated modeling but
does really speak to a pretty
fundamental understanding of what's
going on with that patient and how we
can try and give clinicians information
that is informative for them and and
helpful also back to the patient the
final example you know by this point the
the patient's of hopefully all recovered
but even after they get better many of
those people will eventually relapse
it's you know an unfortunate truth that
many mental health conditions are
actually recurring and people will you
know often dip in and out of good at
versus bad periods over the course of
their life but the the individual
journey that one person goes through is
quite noisy right if you take this
figure on the left this is what it might
look like if you have you know 200
people and they're all going on their
own you
journeys and that can actually be pretty
challenging either for a clinician to
predict upfront offer a machine learning
model to also try and predict what that
individual pathway might look like and
so this was a study done by a biostats
group they used the L CMM package to fit
late latent class mixture models which
basically say out of all of the
different individual journeys that are
going on can we come up with more
representative classes like types of
response that people generally go on
turns out you can you look on the right
and you can actually see these somewhat
more interpretable outcomes and then you
can actually try and predict those
instead so a clinician instead of having
to worry about the specific nuances of
what that person's journey might look
like would instead just get a heads-up
saying this is someone who looks like
they're gonna maybe follow a trajectory
that looks generally bad versus this
looks like someone who's going to be on
a trajectory it looks fairly okay and
then again that can be used to allocate
resources to the health system it can be
used to motivate the the individual
patient and help them stay better once
they are better so I hope that this talk
has has convinced you I think there are
is that mental health isn't just a huge
field of opportunity for people who have
an r background or a data science
background that want to make a
difference individual patients I think
that in I've shown a bunch of cases
where new technology particularly
implemented through our stats can
improve mental healthcare right now not
only can they help but there's actually
a ton of different places where we can
do a much better job it's not just one
specific area that's kind of hyper
developed it really is a green field
where people can help with many
different problems and it's not just
research and development we can do this
in the real world with real patients
we're doing it right now with tens of
thousands of people being treated every
day you know large health systems are
doing this kind of work there's really
tremendous opportunity for people do
this everywhere and my friends from grad
school made me put this in just because
the first time I came here I was an
attendee and I was in grad school and
you know there's anyone who's in grad
school knows that mental health issues
completely rampant and so I did have to
include some unofficial conclusions the
first one of which is that impostor
syndrome is extremely real but it's
important for everyone to remember that
great data science comes from very
diverse backgrounds right it doesn't
really matter what your experience is
really all you have to do is pick a
problem that you care about and then
pursue it kind of relentlessly and have
the the willingness to learn whatever
you need to learn to do it installed up
packages tidy verse and carrot really
can't change your life it took my life
in a very direct different direction but
between those two packages alone you can
actually have a huge impact on the way
that healthcare is delivered there's an
extreme amount of power just in two
simple are packages that help you do a
you know a tremendous amount with the
code that you have and I probably owe my
own sanity in mental health to Max Kuhn
and his colleagues for the developing
carrot I said this term last night it
was very embarrassing over dinner but
for sure I would have gone crazy if I
had to learn machine learning without
you know infrastructure and support that
helps you be able to do this do
reproducibly do it quickly do it
effectively
yeah there's everything we are hiring if
anyone is interested in you know picking
a problem in mental health and then
using data to try and make it better
definitely give us a shout you can email
me careers at Spring House
[Applause]